sur le web le secret de la longévité
passe par la viralité dans la catégorie
vidéo virale et en a pour tous les goûts
en provenance de partout dans le monde
et au québec
la vidéo la plus viral avoir été produit
et celle ci vous vous en souvenez scène
efficace saisissant un aigle en plein
vol qui agrippe un bébé sur le mont
royal mise en ligne le 18 décembre 2012
cette vidéo cumule plus de 46 millions
de visionnements des millions de
personnes ont cru à l'authenticité de la
scène une scène qui n'a jamais eu lieu
entièrement conçu par quatre étudiants
montréalais dans le cadre d'un travail
d'école près de dix ans plus tard
un d'entre eux a accepté de nous
rencontrer en compagnie de son
professeur de l'époque pour nous parler
de cette expérience qui continue
d'alimenter leurs réflexions sur les
dangers de la viralité alors robin fait
l'ex ans on va commencer par revenir un
peu dans le temps 2012 que la vidéo
était publié félix quand appuyer sur le
bouton envoi qu'est ce qui s'est passé
raconte nous ce moment là et surtout ce
qui arrive après donc le marron de
publier la vidéo sur youtube
récemment nous on a fait un travail
terminé on a terminé une session on est
allé présenter le travail dans qu après
on est allé dans un bar pourvoyeur fêter
leur fin de session
c'est là qu'on a commencé à remarquer on
avait déjà une bonne idée de travail
qualité est là vous voyez les
visionnements monte monte monte sur
youtube sur youtube puis quand même en
temps réel mais je dois dire que je t'ai
peu conscients du tout 2 comme le même
site est quoi ce phénomène d'avoir
quelques
de vue pour l'instant c'est vrai avant
de me coucher là que j'ai regardé puis
je voyais les chiffre monte encore donc
rendu proche de 80 milles mais c'est
vraiment le lendemain matin car je me
suis réveillé on était à 3 millions de
vues où ils s'étaient cécile luxe à
partie puis comment comment commence
sans qu'on voit c'est ce qu'on perd le
contrôle de la situation
je me rappelle c'est le lendemain matin
dans le fond il ya nicolet qui est venu
me chercher étudiants normand qui ne me
chercher chez moi lui avait été contacté
par l'école puis on devait justement à
cause que les médias commencent à
appeler au nahd
les médias se sont emparés de l'histoire
s'ajouter à la viralité du sénat mais
l'étincelle était déjà là donc il y
avait il y avait un buzz sur v détient
un buzz sur internet mais je crois
qu'ici effet que le feu a pris
c'est vraiment le moment où on a dit
c'est un hoax on le fait et le leem et
diaw sont embarqués en fait c'est une
histoire quand même cool tout les grands
réseaux les joints pour aussi un nbc
s'est passé ici
cette surprise les l'effet que ça lui
est rarement
bah oui en fait je comprenais même pas
quand ça se passe et ce qui est ce qui
fait que ça marche et que ça a été si
violent sur nos routes
la recette même si ça peut aider de le
voir de manière chronologique si on est
vraiment sur une situation ou de quelque
chose d'extraordinaire qui s'ajoutent à
une situation ordinaire
dans le fond on dit dans un parc une
journée tout à fait banale et le ya
quelqu'un qui filme son téléphone donc
jusque là tout le monde peut
s'identifier ce vidéo le jeu qu'est ce
qui se passe il ya un aigle qui
attaquent le bébé rien élément de
surprise genre ça choque pas cet élément
de surprise le vin et génère une émotion
qui nous on est vraiment allé dans
quelque chose de ces la porte et c'est
terrifiant de penser qu'un enfant puisse
faire carrément enlevé par aig qui avait
défait qu'on peut regarder sur internet
bug qui soulève des chefs de montagne
il y avait le titre si je crois que ça
les titres c'est vraiment un peu comme
les clips est bizarre c'est que le titre
ça rentre dans le dos à ses auditeurs
aussi le fait qu'on manque le vrai début
à la fin des buts des eaux le temps
aussi ça c'est un faux bébé
donc tout ce qui est là qui veulent
c'est faux fait de le montrer à la fin
mais les gens s'ils doutent et à ce
moment là mais il voit vrai à la fin et
comme ces espèces de connexions
déconnexions aider à faire passer du
four au chip ça rend dans les bus
urbains
ouais il sent dans ses rangs dans l'epr
a créé c'est sûr qu'un ça va chercher là
par la peur ça marche
ouais puis à partir de cette émotion le
quai l'apport je crois que si l'émotion
est assez vive bien sur le coup je crois
pas que les gens vont se concentrer sur
le fait est ce que c'est vrai ou s'il
faut si l'émotion est assez fort je
crois que ça va les faire réagir
tellement fort qu ils vont partager ses
incroyables ces genres c'est qu'est ce
qui se passe c'est plus qu'à le le
discours plus court mais ça serait pas
un peu plus le les gens ont plus et
questionner mais attend un aigle à
montréal ainsi que la terre ça qu'est ce
qui se passe le pilat les débats peuvent
gens recommencent et des experts qui
voient ce soit on était visuels ou les
ornithologues cd boloss centenaire je
mens la première que la valorisation qui
ça peut être mieux vivre ça continue
encore plus le spi you des sites des
gens qui ont une image plus on vraiment
entouré les défauts et situation devenue
virale aussi mais vous vous avez
encouragé à titre de professeure à les
encourager
en fait c'est un des objectifs c'est de
susciter la viralité c'est un des
critères mais maintenant vous l'avez
plusieurs critères là dans vos courses
et s'assume et non parce que pourquoi on
a commencé de surveiller les médias nous
surveillait pas non mais on a on savait
des appels
est ce que vous avez fait quelque chose
non l'alligator ont été appelés par les
six l'alligator dans une rue de villers
et les gens se posent la question posée
la question des en fait des courriels
d'anciens du nahd 1 benjani gaudinat pas
nous attendre à un étudiant fait un
petit session comment mouche je pense
que c'est un succès en terre académique
puis d'avoir été vu par combien de
millions de 45 millions à 16,45
milliards cinq cent une vidéo officielle
ça c'est sans compter toutes les vidéos
perdre le contrôle bio dérivés qui ont
eu des millions de wii s'est rendu le
way c'est vrai qu'on peut perdre un peu
le contrôle tes jeux content qu'on ait
que ça va pas durer plus longtemps
j'avais pas me sentir qu'on attend
quelqu'un dessus et parce que vu la
vidéo
il fallait que ça arrête fallait que ça
tombe le masque est tombé
c'est quand même quelque chose pour être
consciente et qui regarde c'est une
chose que des fois que je rencontre des
gens inconnus
puis-je explique qu est ce que je fais
je vais vous la vidéo de l'aide tout le
monde le sait comme tout le monde dans
le descriptif des vidéos youtube le
lendemain on dit que c'est un canular
des mois après je voyais des gens qui
débattait prenez pas l'effort d'aller
lire la description des vidéos youtube
qui disait c'est un canular
débattez en dessous voyez le danger est
là et on parle de désinformation à
fausses nouvelles
c'est quand les gens sont paresseux
finalement séparé ce fut aussi une
réaction c'est qu'on parlait de l'effet
de surprise qui génère une émotion
je veux que les gens sont en mode
rationnel je vais vérifier d'où ça vient
est-ce que ça ce projet tv sont plus ces
motifs dont ils vont partager donc félix
robin si vous avez été surpris par à
tout l'impact de cette vidéo il ya
toulouse en celle de l'aigle et du bébé
peut-être que l'avenir aussi vous
surprendre
impressionnant c'est un domaine qui est
en constante évolution je pense qu'on
était encore dans l'enfance
du domaine puis ça va juste continuer
c'est un colonel à tout ce qui est laid
le diplo ning l'intelligence
artificielle ça change ça change ça
change vraiment beaucoup de choses mais
ça devient j'ai un nouveau un nouvel
ensemble aussi pour la création pour les
artistes mais c'était moi ce que je vois
arriver dans le futur c'est que les
houthis et démocratise de plus en plus
donc de plus en plus c'est un peu
n'importe qui qui va être capable de
travailler comme on dit c'est important
de peut-être commencer à apprendre aux
gens comment hardcore connaître ou avoir
des bons réflexes à sa vidéo et puis je
trouve être un peu plus sceptique le
plus cynique ce niveau là